all right as we continue to broadcast
sunny southern california
the highest tax state in the country uh
for the hour we continue
with california gubernatorial candidate
caitlyn jenner all right
let me let me get to this issue um
on the issue of girls transgender
sports created a controversy
that was interesting to me and your
comments to joy behar we got bigger
problems
yes then pronouns in the state of
california
uh my uh joy bae haar and i agree on
nothing but i thought
i was very gracious of you and i agreed
with you i don't think she did it on
purpose
no no most people honestly my mother at
times misgendered me
by the way my mother yeah okay
she was during world war ii she was
a parts inspector for the avenger
aircraft she is a patriot i love her to
death she's living up in idaho
my mother loves you
watches you every night no thank you
she watches you every night calls me
after the show to discuss
everything on hannity so in 10 days
she turns 95. i'm calling mom her name
her name is esther
okay a quick little maybe to the camera
happy birthday
of course i've always a comment esther
happy birthday god bless you and
you're smart you're in idaho and caitlyn
is paying weight
and by the way i'm dumb i'm in new york
caitlin's in california
big part happy birthday you're in our
love thoughts and prayers
yeah oh she will she will go crazy on
that one anyway
i just had to do that you know so but
but girls transgender sports
people that like joy that say the wrong
thing
joy that says i mean you know i i
mentioned a second ago my mom sometimes
you know when she gets upset you know
she i i don't have a problem with that
the community has a bigger problem
with that than i do um i stick with my
statements that i made
um i think um uh we have to make sure
that the integrity of girl sports is
there i think that's extremely important
um but it's uh
there's more to it than just what i said
because i just said biological boys in
sports
there's more to it than that and i think
in the future i will explain more of
that
but for me as a
a trans woman
um i think role models are extremely
important
for young people trans issues people
struggle with big time
our suicide rate is nine times higher
than the general public
and um for me to be a role model for
them
uh to be out there i am running
for governor of the state of california
who would have ever thunked that we've
never even had
a woman uh
governor but some are mad at you that's
i that's i don't you know i
i move on i want to be a role model and
i think the and to be a leader
and i think the most important thing as
a leader
that you can do is your compassion your
honesty
um and i think that sometimes is very
lacking
in politics so uh
i want to be an example uh to all people
not just trans people but this is what
why on the sports side of it though why
don't they why did you
how you came down on the sports side of
the issue
i don't know why to be honest with you i
don't know why they keep asking matt
what do you think sean i don't know
why do they keep asking me that question
uh
great question it is a good question
but um we can deal with that there's
more problems here in the state of
california
than that now well understood and
there are i want to get into honestly to
me
sean my issues
i'm standing on my back porch a couple
of years ago i'm watching 200-foot
flames come in
coming up the hill at me why
17 miles away in chatsworth
a transformer blew
a few hours later it traveled 17 miles
i had to eventually evacuate my house it
was so intense we had not had it burned
there in 35 years it was so intense
um we need to upgrade our grid our
electrical system
um i think that's a position where we
work with the electrical companies
and sacramento um i don't think
sacramento and the taxpayers should do
all of that they're already paying
enough
these rolling blackouts just like
wildfire rolling blackouts
i i put a generator at my house just
because every time the wind blows
they turn off everything because they're
afraid some system is going to spark
and start a fire um we also
when i stood there watching this fire
come at me i never
saw now i love the fire department i
love these guys
they're out there but when it was coming
at my house i never saw one helicopter i
never saw one fire truck i didn't even
hear a siren
granted i live in a more rural area and
they were probably over protecting more
houses
but we need to do a better job we need
an early detection system when it comes
to fires
i've seen so many of them in malibu i've
lived there for 48 years
um and the biggest thing and the most
important thing is that they
jump on a fire as quick as possible and
put it out when it's small
and once it gets away from them they
can't you know would you allow
controlled burns isn't there a science
behind forestry
is that science being ignored in this
state yes
because when i watch it manhart i lived
in santa barbara i watched hope branch
hope ranch burned down after i had just
left the state
yes um uh yes forest management is
extremely important
yeah just like at my house and it's not
even forest management at my house
the reason my house made it because they
say you have to keep
any brush 50 or 75 feet i think i had 75
feet clearance
when the fires came they just went
around my house so fast
it was gone because it's moving very
fast so
it's almost the same thing for forest
management just a little bit of
preparation
you know uh and my house made it but
five houses around me were burnt to the
ground
lives were destroyed we we now went
through
this this worldwide pandemic
very huge differences between say red
states
florida california what would you have
done differently if you were the
governor
with covert 19. first of all kevin
newsom
on this issue has been absolutely
horrible
okay he's used it as a political tool in
this state
to shut it down to control people and
that should not happen he's destroyed
businesses
thousands of businesses were destroyed
restaurants destroyed
not being able to open up um he should
have done a better job
i don't blame anybody back in march of
2020.
i don't blame the federal government uh
for coming down and saying we're gonna
shut this country down
quickly and they did but i don't think
anybody had any idea how it was going to
be a political game to reopen
as you said some states have done very
well you
mentioned florida we've done a terrible
job
easy example florida
orlando disney world opened up
nine months ago uh anaheim
disneyland opened up six days ago
we're talking nine months of shutting
disneyland down
when it didn't have to be shut down um
and the list of that goes over and over
and over and just his
total mismanagement of this process
did you would you if you had to pick
governors in the country
because like new york newsome whitmer
murphy wolf they all have the executive
orders for nursing homes which
people don't seem to talk about right
are there two or three governors that
you look at in the country that you
think
are doing a great job that you if you
become governor would like to be
texas is doing a great job i honestly i
would have coordinated with those people
i would have been calling them
and talking what's working for you
what's not working for you
it becomes and i look at the successful
ones
they've all been a a collaboration
between
private business and government would
you open the state of california
completely
tomorrow absolutely open it right up
actually you know what it's just don't
close in and out burger before i leave
it's even on a small scale kind of
working already
about three weeks ago uh it was rumored
and rightfully so it was rumored that i
was looking in to run for governor
the next day gavin newsom has a press
conference says the state is opening up
july 15th i'm laying there in bed and
watching this and i'm saying
yes it's already working um
yeah well by the way he's blaming he's
blaming this recall
on q anon anti-vaxxers and
anti-immigration
uh citizens yeah i'm pro-illegal
immigration i i i i want to organize
we really have to pro-legal immigration
whatsapp you're pro-legal legal
immigration
yes pro-legal immigration sorry did i
miss the legal part
yeah thanks for catching me yeah you got
my back sean i appreciate that oh i
thought no i know i knew what you were
saying yeah
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else